we got a group of students who are
coming in to the mosque to go ahead and
visit anyone we all you re going phones
us up and says hey I want to visit you
guys at the mosque over there and see
what you guys talking about if you don't
they don't sound like that but even if
the people that sound like that want to
come in we'll show you guys some love so
let's go talk to this group and try to
dispel some of the myths the
misconceptions and deliver the message
of peace the message of purpose this
Deen this beautiful way of life
Islam let's go something really enjoyed
it's always great to come and learn more
about the faith and also to have folks
on site answer questions so there's no
misunderstandings as we kind of move
forward so thank you for the time
especially the females
what's great Keystone Keystone thank you
guys for for coming out thank you no
thank you thank you for the thank you no
[Music]
it was really good it was very like mine
opening and like allows you like to see
past those layers and barriers at
society like plays out and shows you
that they're not true and it's a lot
much more behind it thank you guys for
visiting us thank you very much yes I
did it was very educational I learned a
lot about the Islamic faith certainly
there's some personally I agree and
disagree with but I think overall it was
a valuable experience especially for
those who are non practicing members of
faith do you recommend people come to
visit us here at the mosque yes I do
actually been thinking about myself
converting over to Islam not because of
the fashion or because of my friends but
because I want to be closer to God okay
let's do we're doing one right here all
right thank you guys again for visiting
us thank you
peace peace be with you very much it's
icy immerse students
perspective would you recommend for more
people to come and learn from the
Muslims to come here to visit them
awesome
absolutely absolutely it's important to
change misconceptions so the only way to
do that is by learning more about it
thank you so much would you invite
people to come visit a mosque oh yeah
absolutely we had a great time at the
Moscow to invite anybody to come and
check it out and it's fascinating and
enjoyable thank you so much thank you
very much god bless you guys heard some
of the recommendations by some of the
not yet Muslims out there who visited
from the professor's the teachers and
the students if you have not if you're a
faculty member if you're a professor
you're a teacher and you're watching
this and you want your students to get
the full grasp the full picture of who
Muslims are what they believe what is
Islam about do what these wonderful
teachers and students did they visited
Muslims at a mosque with the intention
and the hope to develop a better
understanding because with
misunderstanding and deliberate attempts
to fuel hate and this is what the hey
provocateurs want to do because in this
crazed division through this hate this
leads to violence
oppression and we don't want that as
humans do we so this is the first step
it's getting educated and clearing up
these doubts clearing up these
eradicating many of these fears so visit
a mosque like they did again if you're a
professor a teacher you're just an
average person by yourself or with a
group of people it doesn't matter bring
your whole family make it a family event
call up the mosque here in Chicago you
can go ahead and call them MCC if you're
in Chicago and if I'm available
I could be your tour guide the mosque
asked for me tell them that you want to
make it a family event invite as many
people as possible say I want to tour
the mosque Friday's usually is a great
day after the Juma prayer and but if not
Friday's you want to make it another day
doesn't matter just come on in if I'm
there I like to meet you guys if I'm not
there somebody else will be there to
help answer your questions
eradicate many of the fears and
misunderstandings but take that first
step and you know what even you know
let's say you can't make it you can't
make it call us